[Applause]
[Applause]
this is our third animal friends of
Independence and today is the
inauguration of our Independent Spirit
Award now this is really the first time
I think that independent filmmakers have
joined together to honor the
achievements of their own and we're so
thrilled that it's happening here today
you know one person alone in a room and
concealer film but between that person
their inspiration and the realization is
an army of people complex equipment and
a fortune
so it seems that any person whose
logical or the stang would not want to
be a filmmaker
traditionally they say that one who
accept the tortured ones with him but we
here because of our budget seem to pick
up the shoestring and we prove once
again that small budgets can indeed make
big movies now today's event would not
be possible at all if it weren't with a
very very generous sponsorship
I'd like to introduce from the Office of
Film Commission Wagner who would like to
say a few words
[Applause]
or very successful in deciding this
already
exciting award ceremony
[Applause]
his liaison for the entertainment world
dynamo jars
we actually have a proclamation for us
from their brother yard
good afternoon we are Bradley very much
one of you attend this luncheon today
because you're honoring something very
close to his heart independent an
entrepreneurial spirit that was born in
Los Angeles
that has been fostered here ever since
we've been founded since 1908 when the
first full-length feature film is filmed
in downtown Los Angeles we're very
excited that you all take on the mantle
of creativity of Independence of bucking
the system sometimes a going on the
avant-garde and making your mark in the
film world we wanted to take this
opportunity to congratulate each and
every one of you today for all your hard
work the important strides you make for
the film industry they like to call it
Victoria Wozniak - presenter on behalf
of your organization with the
proclamation we need to do one of the
last lines it is important in a land
founded by free thinkers and people by
myriad of cultures the support diversity
of creative endeavors independent
spirits in the arts reflects and
celebrates unique opportunity afforded
artists in this country and honors the
truths upon which it was built down
therefore I Tom Bradley there the city
of Los Angeles on behalf of its citizens
we hereby proclaim today March 22nd as
and it's spirit day in Los Angeles
[Applause]
[Music]
where's the executive director of the
independent feature project is really
along with Victoria Wasson and our
president whom you have met the mover
and shaker on I do mean that
without these ladies we wouldn't be here
today there wouldn't be that
organization and this tribute is as much
to them as to all of us and I would like
to now introduce Lynette Mathis the
executive director of the independent
feature project West
[Music]
absolutely a pleasure to be here I'm
extremely glad that you're all here to
share it with us today it's a very
special occasion
the first 1986 Independent Spirit Awards
inaugurated today as jr. just said I
guess I'd like to just step back a
little bit sort of for an overview I was
thinking about what I would like to say
today and it occurs to me that the
movies are really an American obsession
that millions of us is 8 going into the
movies into the great American pastime
and directly or indirectly the movies
affect all our lives but film is not
only our most popular art form it's also
the most accessible to the most people
the most democratic art form if you will
yet what we must think will be most
often think of as a form of
entertainment purely a leisure activity
is also one of the most potent forms of
mass communication and persuasion known
in our society yet in the United States
the ability to practice feature
filmmaking is concentrated in relatively
few
that fine work comes out of this system
is undeniable but more often what
emerges is formulaic predictable and in
a very real sense middle-of-the-road in
this to mean that the RF of filmmaking
is too often overwhelmed by the business
of filmmaking but a counter trend is at
work and it's the feisty and seemingly
irrepressible American independent film
movement as exemplified by every film
represented here today and the many
other fine independent films in the past
year
these maverick films by maverick
filmmakers have proven themselves
artistically and dramatically daring and
commercially viable their makers many of
them here today are setting the quality
standard for the entire movement and are
doing so brilliantly this movement which
is alive and well across our land takes
us in space it's a certain assumption
and that is the
that there will always be an audience
for passionate courageous films that
entertain us and enrich us movies with
something on their mind it is in the
interest of moviegoers arts patrons
finance seers Arts Council's film
Commission's distributors and exhibitors
even corporate America in short all of
us to make sure that their work
continues to be possible and available
to the American public and on a somewhat
lighter tongue since we're here to
recognize the achievements of the
Independent Spirit and filmmaking and to
dine I'd like to play with the food
analogy just a little bit and propose a
recipe for Independent Spirit and it
would go something like this you must
start with an obsession to create and to
communicate and ideally you throw in
some raw talent to this you add 1/2 cup
of audacity 3/4 cup of passion and
finally 3 pounds of perseverance
the independent feature project is a
unique support system for those with
audacity and passion and perseverance
who may yet be in need of information or
friends or support for contacts in the
process of financing producing and
distributing their independent projects
we are an organization founded by and
governed by independent future
filmmakers with over 800 members and
growing the IFP West is the largest part
of an expanding national network that
includes the IFP East in New York the
Illinois feature project in Chicago and
the IFP Northern California one of our
objectives as an organization is to take
the lead in helping to create a proud
and distinct public identity for
American independent film and we feel
that today is a very important step in
that direction
however the IFP West is also active
year-round we hope that if you're not
already familiar with us our activities
our programs or services they'll take a
target to learn more and to become
involved and now I would like to
introduce Ann Kimmel a member of our
board of directors and a co-chairman of
the awards event invitation
[Applause]
it's a real honor with an organization
that dreamed up the real gold award it's
a special award that we invented to show
our appreciation to an individual whose
inspiration and help has the the
independent filmmaking movement and the
IFP feels deserves recognition this year
the award is was voted unanimously by
the board to to be given to David
Puttnam the award which is an original
by a carol of orginal piece of art
actually by carol baz lurman it's
something that we want to give to david
who is an advisory board member and
whose works as a producer include
chariots of fire killing field local
hero midnight express among others
his work is really a tribute to what's
possible the integrity that is possible
to maintain while making independent
projects sometimes even perhaps even
more easily than a dis maintain a sort
of integrity in making projects with
larger budgets or with more with more
people involved David has served as an
inspiration to us in many different ways
he's really spearheaded the resurgence
of the in Britain of the
movement of low-budget projects and
independent projects he keeps his budget
slow while making sure that the money is
spent on the screen he's also a champion
of young talent he takes his projects
from inception to the end I mean
sometimes I think in in town here it's
easy to get worked up and get involved
with deal-making sometimes more than
moviemaking and David is someone who's
inspirational in terms of being involved
with the really would a project means
from from inception to the end
he's prolific David has made nearly 20
feature films and television productions
in the last 15 years the man is
consistently shared with the IFP his
expertise not just in the nuts and bolts
of filmmaking which we all know is very
important but also in maintaining an
ethical perspective in filmmaking he
he'll come and speak with before IFP
gatherings and really helped us question
who we are and what we're doing and what
our responsibilities as filmmakers might
be and that's something I think is
extremely valuable his he's warm
insightful he's an accessible gelt
fellow I think David Puttnam is a match
[Laughter]
David I'm afraid today is in the Far
East as it happens I were raised as his
close friend and a colleague to accept
the word on his behalf
the gentleman who will be receiving his
award I had worked hand in glove with
David for the past five years in David's
word he's made it possible he's made
possible all of his best work the film
it films that he has been associated
with include local hero kale The Killing
Fields and most recent recently the film
were all I'm sure looking forward to
seeing the mission he was formerly the
president of theatrical motion picture
productions at Warner Brothers
and most recently has joined the ranks
of independent producers by forming a
new company with Sydney Pollack called
Mirage productions I'd like to introduce
mr. mark Rosenberg good thank you
David asked me to come today to accept
this award for him I'm very honored to
do so and to be here he unfortunately is
touring the Far East including a trip in
a few days to the Philippines which is
interested in a great deal so he is
sorry that he couldn't be here himself
in talking to him on the phone about
accepting this award mm you should know
that David considers the IFP to really
be the single most important filmmaking
organization he knows of here and it was
a very important thing for him that he
was honored in this way he feels as
independent I think as any producer who
has had a major studio executive like
myself to have to talk to over the last
five years he feels as independent as
any producer could and I think he feels
a kind of that his soul mates are in
this room in many ways and certainly
from his point of view the future of
independent filmmaking just without
going on too long the thing about David
that I think made Warner Brothers as a
as a public company and myself keenly
interested in working with him at every
turn comes down to a word that Ann used
in her remarks which is responsibility
as independent as David is I think that
it is his singular talent that he takes
every frame every every scene every
piece of casting every every dollar that
goes into a film every minute of time as
his personal responsibility and
therefore the films reflect something in
David that very few producer
can earn in in the hustle and bustle of
Hollywood and that is a kind of personal
trademark on his films I'm very honored
to accept the award for him because now
that I've crossed the table and gone to
the other side of it I can only say that
as a close friend of David's all I can
do in the next two years is aspired to
do anything close to what he's done with
that I thank you and David thank you and
is very very honored to be to get this
award we're so so very pleased to have
Peter Coyote with us today as our host
yes and a guest speaker this wonderful
and very respected actor has done 16
films in just five years his versatility
and very special talents are outstanding
and every film he makes from thomas
riddle his first independent movie to
the smash hit Beauty to strangers kiss
Cross Creek Heartbreakers and his most
recent film jagged edge Peter believes
it's vitally important to be active
culturally artistically
and politically he served as chairman of
the State Arts Council for three years
and donated and donates his services for
one month out of every year to the
Sundance Institute he recently completed
a Disney film just titled time flyer and
did an exceptional performance in the TV
movie the week who'll hear the child's
cry
he looks forward to producing and
directing and is actively pursuing those
goals well ladies and gentlemen I'm so
thrilled to pretty to bring to you mr.
Peter Coyote
is this an unnatural act Thanks when I
got off the plane today and they handed
me this twenty page script and I
muttered something about first rehearsal
being opening night they told me but you
get to give a speech so I did have
something I wanted to say about
independent film and try to make it
brief I cut out all the periods I've
been a student of Zen Buddhism for a
long time
twelve years and they said a great deal
of meditation one of the things that you
learn is that the fundamental activity
of mind is the production of images that
when your internal dialogue stops what
you're left with is a gland that
produces images produces pictures and
there's nothing esoteric about this it's
just like trying to find your keys or
holding up a dress and a dress shop next
you and you image it and it happens
without language and there's something
about the nature of that imaging which
is something that we all do and share in
common and it seemed appropriate to talk
about that as a fundamental activity of
mind and culture really is no more than
common images of the way we do things
that collective common the images or the
way we do things and that's the way
culture both perpetuates itself and
changes itself and so as image makers we
sit at the fulcrum of both perpetuating
and changing everything about the
culture that we like or don't like and
as members of the culture we also have
to humbly admit that we're the problems
with the culture it's not
this is a self-righteous cadre and the
problems exist outside we are the
culture we are its problems we exist at
the Nexus of change so right now in the
last half of the 20th century a very
exciting kind of epic battle is taking
place psychologically and culturally and
politically and socially logically and
that is the end of one image of the
United States which was freedom which
really meant without limits
free enterprise meant business without
limits and in the last half of the 20th
century freedom has run smack into the
ecology movement or more generally
interdependence the fact that not only
are people and towns and cities but
nations are interdependent there is no
separate existence and I actually see
the independent film movement as the
cultural organ of this interdependent
interdependence I actually think we
should be called the interdependent film
movement because it's only the studio
system that can really be independent
because they have enough money and
enough authority to demand things a
certain way but in fact when you do
things in a restricted framework you
have to get the most out of all of your
resources you have to get the most of
every single person on the film set and
this means the maximal collaboration and
the maximal inspiration because since
you don't have enough money to buy
people's tastes or to buy their
standards they're working by and large
because of belief inspiration the
independent film movement is
decentralized and local far less
centralized in the studio system it's
smaller and quicker in the analogy that
evolution
favors favors lizards / dinosaurs we
would be the lizards
and as I said the relationships between
people are more horizontal they're less
power dynamics well I think it's useful
to see ourselves this way because
oftentimes you hear a lot of poor
mouthing and a lot of stuff about tiny
budgets and this and that and I'm the
great because we don't have any money I
don't think that's the point I think
that doing things within strict limits
is actually an ethical and an aesthetic
position to take willingly that expires
creative problem-solving it's hard to
make a mistake with thirty million
dollars it's hard to get into a hole you
can't get yourself either but it
actually removes to me the possibility
of making creative changes it has an
ethical relationship to indulgence it
acknowledges the fact that the world is
waking up - which is that there are real
and palpable limits to everything we do
and so I think seeing ourselves this way
serves to to reverse a kind of underdog
mentality and helps us to stake a
terrain stake out a kind of turf where
we want to exist and do our work so I
think we have one very real thing to
offer in this coming evolution and I
call it authenticity and I think of
three quick relationships of
authenticity authenticity of imagination
it's within the independent film
movement that a director and a writers
stand the best chance of putting their
vision out authentically I would
challenge anyone in this room to take
any twenty films from a studio and cut
the directors credits off and identify
the director and that's not a
testimonial to the lack of talent of the
directors out there it's an indictment
of a kind
corporate bureaucratic group think that
homogenizes rough edges and takes
individuality away so we own that
authenticity of our imagination we are
the ones that recognize that the spinal
telephone is truly a universal party
line and when you speak in images you
don't need simultaneous translation that
because the fundamental activity of mind
is images we can speak from mind to mind
and culture the culture without
subtitles
without even translations that's
something we own as a movement that no
one else does we have the authenticity
of our perceptions which is because we
honor our authentic perceptions we're
free to include ironies contradictions
absurdities that protect us from
propaganda and stupid ideological
positions and that also reaffirms the
important the importance of particulars
this person this word this gesture which
gets all too wiped out in the kind of
generalized mass culture and finally we
stand for the authenticity of behavior
that through our observation we get to
replicate what we see as real behavior
not the official story of what behavior
is and so authenticity finally is a kind
of faith in the universe kind of faith
that what comes through your imagination
is accurate and true and integrative and
at its deepest understanding it's a
faith in self and I would just like us
all to hold that in mind when we say
when we write or when we say action
here goes the first rehearsal the findi
Awards this is it a product of the
American feature project West it honors
individuals and organizations who
actively promote and support independent
filmmaking see the award itself is a
shoestring you get the symbology painted
with film sprockets and a clear
plexiglass pyramid which stands for some
higher spiritual value and here to
present the findi Awards is Steven
Railsback who began his career by
starting in Elia Kazan's the visitors
who worked extensively in theater and on
TV returning to movies for the stuntman
for which he won unanimous critical
acclaim subsequent movies included the
Golden Seal torchlight and life force
he's currently starring in the six-hour
miniseries spear fields daughter ladies
and gentlemen
thank you the distributor is a lifeline
between the filmmaker and his audience
this finding winner has been in business
only a little over three years but it's
unique and caring approach has made it a
pretty aminute distributor of
independent films a partial list would
include Angelo my love el norte 1918 the
times of Harvey Milk Latino and the
upcoming home of the brave for his
commitment to independent films the IFP
is proud to present this affinity award
to Senna come here to accept is melody
corn bro I recall this this morning he
was sitting at Kennedy on an airplane
for two hours plane never took off
so I quote and said would we accept this
so this is very short center culinary
national films and I rejoice Minh thank
you very much
without investment capital the best
movie in the world will never be made
however film Dallas which is devoted to
investment in a production of
independent features has made several
buying films possible in its current
portfolio or choose me the dirt bike kid
the kiss of the Spider Woman and trip to
bountiful the IFP West is pleased to
present is Finn the award film ballast
for significant work with independence
here to accept as a president and chief
executive officer of film ballast as
well as an active member of the IFD West
Advisory Board mr. Sam grog
[Applause]
well I'm amazed that most of the people
here who have probably had to say no to
some projects still decided to give me
some more you come down give us time
we're we're in the business not only of
handing out money but making sure that
we gather plenty more capital to put
into the independent motion picture
business I have a strong belief that art
and business can live together can
Cowen's coexist and can too many sees I
guess can collaborate I also have a
strong belief that awards are not only
meant to be given to honor
accomplishment but to provide motivation
and this award is going to motivate me
to make sure there's plenty of capital
available for you to make pictures in
the future
[Applause]
project West I'd like to thank again
Sena comm film Dallas for being such
good friends thank you very much I'd
like to introduce certainly a friend of
independent films and one of the patrons
of this particular event Len Coleman of
Kodak began as a Kodak Park messenger at
17 and today's the vice president and
general manager of marketing of Kovacs
motion picture and audio-visual products
division he was president of the S
period and period P period t period
period which I'm sure you'll tell us
about LEM for two years and an active
member of the Motion Picture Academy of
Arts and scientists he's an avid
collector of cameras and also a great
friend and supporters of independent
film never never following act on a
stage that has a child or an animal
as a guest speaker never follow at
element articulate movie actor you can
never do as good a Japanese repeater I
complimentary Kodak Company for many
years has been a friend of the
independent film maker we have felt that
it's a very important part of our
business as we hope you feel your
business is a part of others before
films that are actually up to date for
nomination were all shot using Houston
color-
I look at the shoestring this on there
and say that even though you continue to
say you're on a limited budget and these
should have the ability to use the best
film in the world
this year's debut of the Independent
Spirit Award marks the first time that
independent filmmakers have joined
together for the express purpose of
honoring their own the independent
feature project West nominating
committee had a hard time finalizing the
nomination there were so many excellent
independent entries and the IFP West
membership had a more difficult task in
voting in a very real sense every
nominee is a winner since it's certainly
a big tree or a triumph actually
finalized the finishing producing
independent film
this award this award was designed by
Carol BA Suleman and it breaks its own
symbology the top features an abstract
bird representing us the independent
filmmaker it's taking flight from a
classical column which represents the
Hollywood establishment I had to double
check and clutched in its talons is a
ubiquitous shoestring with pockets these
ballots were tabulated by high FPS West
Price Waterhouse namely Jim block
and we're honored to begin the
Independent Spirit Award by introducing
a man who is one of the most influential
and celebrated cinematographers of our
time I have my own story about him in a
minute
he's nominated for six Academy Awards
he's won three for his very unique
unique and innovative work all of his
projects are endowed with the richness
of his own Humanity in his current
acclaimed film Latino which he wrote
produced and directed as a powerful
reflection of his social conscience and
exceptional creativity I was impressed
by his courage in late 1967 when he came
to the kashfari and dropped into a
digger crash pen for about five days
while people were trying to steal his
cameras to sell to buy drugs and we're
feeding 1,500 people a day and he was
right there a hundred percent I'm proud
to introduce an old friend I was going
to present the Independent Spirit Award
for cinematography mr. Haskell Wexler
Peter didn't say that that's the place
that I was in haight-ashbury is where he
lived
[Laughter]
you should have seen them then but I
must say after hearing your remarks
Peter hearing what you said you haven't
you've developed and you present your
views socially useful you they look
different you're still the same good guy
I was just going to come up here and
read these nominations but I saw the
definition of the word independent there
and it says not subject to control by
others not supported self-governing
autonomous free and I know that a lot of
the discussion about independence has to
do with being low-budget being small
being mobile being dedicated to having
perseverance but also being independent
means having something to say about what
you're doing feeling some passion for
not just the technique of filmmaking but
the end result because you know we're
all extremely privileged really
privileged people who can't have the
ability the knowledge the profession to
be able to gather those images that
Peter was talking about and put them on
to a screen to to make people cry to
make people think
make people feel and with that privilege
comes a responsibility responsibility
not just to the box office not just to
one's own personal ego but to the risk
of sounding fancy to to our fellow human
beings we're at a point in the history
of civilization where we can blow
ourselves up but some quirk of a
computer where we have not been able to
successfully to deal with the problems
of mankind and I think that as
independent filmmakers we have to offer
we have to offer our audiences something
of the passion something of the interest
something of the conviction that big
corporate conglomerates are not bent to
do because they have other interests
their primary interest is not art and
the fullest meaning of the word their
primary interest is the common
denominator it doesn't mean it has to be
weird eh but I do think that it means
that there has to be a dedication of
what we do with our independence to work
at it so that in future generations will
say that this group of filmmakers made
the world a better place now literally
that you know the names of the nominees
for the best cinematography Michael Ball
house for an after-hours
my kitchen producing toyomi chikorita
for trouble and mine and a Barry
Sonnenfeld for blood simple
[Applause]
[Applause]
to present the awards for screenplay and
director of an American independent film
our first very versatile and
sought-after actress who seems to be
working now I didn't write it who seems
to be working nonstop on television and
movies playing major roles in such
productions as Cujo et the howling tan a
secret admirer she is starring in three
soon-to-be released films titled
critters shadow play in the white dragon
the last which was the very first Co
venture between the United States and
Poland after today we can all see her
again soon in the upcoming sin of
innocence airing on CBS television on
Tuesday March 26 ladies and gentlemen
miss Dee Wallace Stone
you know we had all that anyway we did
et I would have rapped his brain had
some great join EP is an actress has
been an Emmy Award and Golden Globe
winner and the Broadway Award winner won
also the British Academy Awards she was
nominated for an Academy Award for the
creation of her role flow and the film
Alice doesn't live here anymore
she lost that award to Ingrid Bergman
which to quote her isn't chopped liver
her TV appearances sweep the ratings
even against the world series a past
member of sag board of directors a
political activist author and mother of
Laura Dern why it comes to that their
current passion is producing and
starring and a future production of her
screenplay based on the life of Martha
Mitchell I'd like to present miss Diane
Ladd
before I go on with the script here has
so elegantly precisely and specifically
put forth a much needed opinion and
point of view by the mailed logic rules
day I'd like to put forth the emotional
female point of view first of all it is
my privilege and pleasure to be here for
I feel that this group today which we
are alone is possibly the most needed
and the most important group of the
decade if not the century and the reason
is when the Pope came to visit our
country he said to us here in the West
do not let commercialism be a criterion
of culture but of course we know that it
is
and this group here a support group from
one another I'm amazed at the talent in
this room and the thing I like most
about it is the lack of pretentiousness
I like it so much that I have suggested
to Lynette Matthews that perhaps every
two weeks are once a month we could get
this establishment or another one to
offer us a room where we could meet
where we could share without being
divided by the game to share our ideas
and our hopes you mentioned before
Peterson credits and awards my finest
production was the birth of my daughter
laura dern and sitting next to her is a
wonderful actor Kyle MacLachlan who
starred in Newtons these are the young
people who will follow our support in
our lead and I believe that culture is
as powerful a weapon as a bomb any time
and I want to thank the group that has
put this lunch on and I hope that it
will continue with all of our joining
and our support and you've of course met
Victoria Wozniak and Jeannie Lucas and
Ann Kimmel but you have not met two
other people who have given a great deal
of time and effort on behalf of all of
us
one is the lady who produced a film that
I did miss Gwen feel when would
and another is our mando Pina and
without further ado I shall say now
whenever you see a really outstanding
film it's important to remember that in
the beginning was the word and all right
Mac and iced and honey somebody up
there's got to be listening because
right now
today's nominees have given us glorious
words and stories of which we all thank
you
or they're very exceptional and
innovative screenplays the nominees are
Joel and Ethan Coen for Blood Simple Tom
Cole for smooth talk mr. Horton foot or
tripped about
mr. Joseph minyan for after hours and
the winner is
[Applause]
I'm very tell you I listened with great
interest to Peters words about
interdependence I'm the living proof the
past six years have been a number of
people to achieve certain things with
Bountiful I was bountifully blessed with
first of all my agent too many years ago
insisted that I keep the copyright when
it was done in television so that I can
control its destiny through all these
years and then Island which has proved
so helpful as a distributor and for
executive producers Sandrock enjoy on
earth for a wonderful darling
been Waggaman who was our producer Peter
Masterson the wonderful crew and the
cast and of course miss Joni paid who
did so much to make it digs destroy
anything that I think it is because of
our performance and my wife and children
who are so used to independent
filmmaking
and they have all pitched in through the
years and enormous support I'm so
grateful for a group like this because I
felt very lonely we're really kind of
wandering around New York and trying to
get these projects together and to know
that there are a lot of us out here to
help each other and to inspire each
other was a real pioneer in producing
and directing had his own special
philosophy of filmmaking he said we
never make sport of religion politics
race or mothers a mother never gets hit
with a custard pie
go on mothers-in-law I can identify
mothers among men only mothers are
locking it with their country hi
but mother's never see her you can't
ever get married I don't Cecil B DeMille
have different ideas now he said that
the way to make a film is to begin with
an earthquake and work out to a climax D
we can take this anguish I don't know
how any of our nominated directors feel
about these philosophies but they have
certainly created their own very unique
expressions of creative vision for their
very outstanding direction of an
American independent film the nominees
are joy chakra for smooth talk Josh
Chopra
and Joel Cohen for blood sample
Peter Masterson for the trip to
bountiful Martin Scorsese for
after-hours and the winner is we have a
time Joel Coen for blood sample that
thing for mr. Cohen is Ben Vereen volts
I hope I pronounced that correctly well
for Joel :
thank you very much on a given day Daily
Variety said rocky for opened 2234
screams on a particular Friday at no
time during the life of Blood Simple
where there are 120 Brits we did well
the other winner is Martin Scorsese
and except for Martin Scorsese is one of
the families producers instar griffin
dunne Marty sorry can't be here he's on
location in Chicago but he wanted me to
thank the Independent Film Commission
and say that one of the things he liked
about making after hours was that it
broke him out of a box of being known as
a director of just high budget pictures
and he was reinvigorated to be on a set
where he didn't have time to sit down he
managed to get more camera setups than
he did during taxi driver and it was a
wonderful experience for him and he
encourages other mainstream directors to
to look back and challenge themselves
with other budgetary ways and he thanks
you all very much for this award
we're just supposed to say don't let you
all anteater get back up here and I just
think what they've done is fantastic I
don't know probably nobody here is as
small-minded as I am but I can't help
thinking about these guys that aren't
here for the awards that they're working
Moctezuma Esparza has received over a
hundred honors and awards his credited
as the producer of the award-winning
film The Ballad of Gregorio Cortez
and a regular active Dreams he's also
the founder and president of Buena
Vision cable TV and East Los Angeles mr.
Esparza is currently developing and
producing several projects including
Robert Redford's next directorial effort
the Milagro Beanfield war a low-budget
feature on apartheid speaking on
independent filmmaking a magnificent
obsession mr. Martin
thank you Peter like a little feverish
from a cold I'm really tickled by the
very idea that I should have been asked
to be a speaker today and as I was
driving over here from the east side of
town I reflected on that and thought
about really the last times that I was
involved in a community that was
dedicated to changing the world and
having an impact on life and culture and
in which I was completely engrossed in
it
through my very life and core into it
and that time it resulted they might get
even dieded by the grand jury two years
in a row facing life in jail 14 years
ago and it took me three years to beat
that rap decided that I would rather
approach changing the world from a more
socially acceptable vantage point that's
when governor Reagan was here in the
state one of those particular moments
was arrested was for interrupting his
speech he didn't like it but in any
event the the idea that I'm now again a
part of a community of independent
minded people because I don't think we
really rather a defendant at all it's
invigorating and it gives me a great
deal of hope to know that I can actually
collaborate and share experiences with
people who wish to change the way we
think as Americans
and wish to open up the possibility that
there are other ways to to be to
recognize that there's a humanity in all
of us and that humanity deserves an
opportunity to be the guiding light for
what we are as Americans
for me that's what film is about and
it's what drove me to the magnificent
obsession of producing The Ballad of
Gregorio Cortez which took quite a while
and was a minor miracle and for which
there are many people I have to thank
one of whom was in the room Tom Bauer
and Bob young and Eddy almost Michael
Houseman who shared that obsession and
who were willing to work for nothing
along with myself and to make a film
that spoke to our humanity and to spoke
to how we don't communicate and by not
understanding each other end up killing
each other which for me what was that
poem was about
and it's other films like janus missing
and a North Bay and Heartland that for
me also opened up the possibility that I
could continue making films that opened
up even in my own experience the
humaneness of other cultures other
people and that allowed me to identify
my own life with them and it's my hope
that all of our work and our dedication
is to that to opening up our lives to be
human beings
that's what I think the potential
opponents and why we should be obsessed
by it
anybody who's had their eyes open at the
movies at all knows a lot about Harry
Dean Stanton and the rest of the world
caught up with his performances Travis
in Paris Texas this role won him the
British Film Critics Circle Award and
the Palm D'Or at Cannes since then he's
done one magic Christmas pretty-in-pink
and recently finished fool for love hair
he's not only acted in over 50 films
he's a singer performed with Joan Baez
Linda Ronstadt Carol King even did the
vocals to the theme song of Paris Texas
and joining Harry Dean is the very
versatile and compelling actress Jane
Alexander audiences are riveted by her
performances whether they see her in the
theater on television or in the movies
she's been nominated for and won
numerous awards including four Oscar
nominations
Broadway's Tony Award and an Emmy for
her moving performance and playing for
time the integrity of her work is
evident in her many films which include
the great white hope Kramer vs Kramer
all the President's Men Testament and
city heat she currently has six new
projects in development please welcome
Miss Jane Alexander
Jane had a little card if you put your
thumb on it registers the stress factor
not stressful you are and I came out I
got the highest mark blue but now that
I'm up here I shouldn't take the test
[Music]
Lynnette Malthus and Jean Lucas I'd like
to thank and advisory board the Board of
Directors I think this is a great idea
it's a guerrilla movement started here
and it came along at the right time
otherwise I'm gonna survive the famous
film director max von Reinhardt said to
be a fine actor one was never put on an
act never on stage and never off and so
Harry Dean and I are not going to read
from this script well we certainly have
many many fine examples of honest acting
to honor today for an exceptional
performance in an American independent
feature film the nominated actors are
Ruben blades for crossover dreams
Tom Bower or Wild Rose mm it watch for
blood simple treat Williams for smooth
talk and the winner is em Emmett waltz
for Blood Simple
[Applause]
he knows I can't do it the no I wouldn't
rather be at the beach in the Sun and
the sand watching the ocean I've got to
thank Joe and Ethan Coen and Barry Sean
fellows and cinematographer I mean I had
nothing to do with this movie they came
and got me I didn't know who they were
they were Joel with 27 29 years old his
brother was 27 they said there was this
script in New York was i interested I
saw unless at least read it again was a
wonderful part as a great role I didn't
know how anyone to make the film but it
was a kind of a Thomas Mitchell and a
and the Sydney Greenstreet type of thing
and I thought well I'll take a shot at
it didn't maybe five years down the line
I'll work it out and do it an important
movie I figured I figured they're headed
for the third bill on an Alabama driving
I had no idea where
at one point and one point in
negotiation the agent said what they
haven't got anything I said well what
are they offering you said they'll give
you they'll give you one percent of the
profit and I said well that doesn't
sound like it's gonna be anything I says
try for some warrants he came back the
next day and said we can get you two
percent of the gross I said wow you're
one great negotiator so really I also
have to think there was a little
wardrobe girl getting her master's at
the University of Texas her name was
Sarah Medina hey and she found that
yellow suit that I wore and there was
one critic that said I looked like a
200-pound yellow Tweety Bird my father
who was a u.s. customs officer up on the
Vermont
Welbeck border always felt my career was
going well if the roles I played had me
wearing a suit and a tie I glad he was
dead when he saw them
I'm very honored I want you to know that
I hope from this point on I can be
considered one of Hollywood's most
eligible bachelors
I also I'd like to thank all people
concerned and also the people who aren't
concerned who came here for honoring my
51st birthday thank you
you know two questions that I've actors
get asked most are how do you remember
all those words and how do you get into
the business and I don't know the answer
to either you look there's one you left
out and that is how long does it take to
learn how to act what's my answer to
that is how long have you got two
questions that actors ask most when they
get into an independent production or do
I have to mortgage my house in order to
do this part and the other is are you
sure this is a go because my agent says
there's another offer and we're honored
to be able to acknowledge some very fine
and boldly inspired performances today
the actress is nominated for their
uniquely outstanding performances in an
American independent film our rosanna
arquette for after-hours laura dern for
smooth talk
Geraldine page for the trip to bountiful
and Lauri singer for trouble in mind
[Applause]
and the winner is
Geraldine page
[Applause]
this is lovely and they're very proud to
have it and I'm glad I didn't listen to
Peter Coyote when in our house he told
me the theater is not worth anything
forget it just meaning yeah
[Laughter]
but I'm so glad this whole thing is here
because anybody who's had to work the
other way knows what a joy it is when
you can finally get something directly
into what's happening I'm going direct
to not pass go into the content and it's
wonderful and I think that another thing
is great about all this is if movies
like Spider Woman and movies by X elixir
can all be under the same roof then we
got freedom of speech really quite an
organization and I think I'm very
honored
[Music]
well I think we've said everything it's
back to Peter Thank You Harry I really I
really do want to say this it's actually
embarrassing to have to read the credits
from great performers like Jane and
Harry but if you didn't have them right
in mind I know that myself my mind would
freeze so I apologize to all of my peers
but um I had to read credits I hope
you'll forgive that this wonderful and
highly respected actress you're gonna
know as soon as they say it was honored
with an Oscar nomination for inspired
work and victor/victoria as well as
winning Golden Globe and People's Choice
Awards for choose me songwriter and the
TV miniseries 79 Park Avenue she began
her career on Broadway and maintains her
attachment to the theatre in the midst
of her busy shooting schedule we all had
to suffer through success me jails have
just starred in the movie clue and has
been in production for a new film called
apology I'm very pleased to introduce
and present the final two Awards with
Lesley Ann Warren
well I'm told to say that it's important
that movies go beyond just preserving
the single fact of our existence or the
collective fact for that minute and the
truly outstanding films not only do that
but raise the film experience to a real
celebration of human resilience and
spirit the nominated films in the
special distinction category are
exceptional examples of those truly
outstanding films this special
distinction category was created in
order to honor those films that were not
strictly American independent films
those of foreign origination or foreign
co-production the nominees are dream
child Rick McCallum and Kenneth trout
producers Gavin Millar director the hit
Jeremy Thomas producer and Stephen
Frears director kiss of the Spider Woman
David Weisman producer hector babenco
director ron serge Silberman and masato
hara producers akira kurosawa director
the winner is
this could be CBS
[Applause]
Sonia say a few words we'd like to call
up here our collaborator our inspiration
hector babenco hello my name is Ana
Brava
[Laughter]
[Music]
well thank you everybody it's a big
surprise it's all a big surprise because
we did it for love and none of this was
supposed to happen it was a little movie
we got together and make it Alan salt
Paulo Brazil and we did it with funny
money and lots of sweat and it was all a
dream that was told to me by
extraordinary man who came up here to
find out why everyone was so excited
about his last film he told me the story
of kiss of the Spider Woman from a book
he read in a hotel room here in the
Beverly Hilton Hector and from the
moment he told me that story I was
hypnotized and we all got caught in his
web and here we are today thank you very
much
I believe that the real impediment to
getting good projects on the screen may
not be a dearth of good writers and
actors or directors but an absence of
creative producers who will hire good
artists give them creative structure and
protect and champion them thank God the
independent filmmakers whose reputations
for risk-taking commitment to ideals and
a touch of madness is giving our
industry a new vitality they make some
of the best films and those films speak
eloquently of the Independent Spirit
nominated for best American independent
feature film or after-hours
produced by Amy Robinson Robert F Cole's
Barry and Griffin done by Ethan Coen
smooth-talk produced by Martin Rosen
the trip to bountiful produced by
Sterling bandwagon and department store
there's nothing in it
the winner is after-hours Robert one of
the things that I like best about good
movies is that for me the characters
live on in my mind like friends I know
and love and this is especially true of
the movies we've produced Charles and
Laura and Jill and Ashiq and in the case
of after-hours Paul and Marcy and Kiki
and all the rest are people I think
about with great fondness and it's very
easy to forgive these movie characters
all their neuroses with great
magnanimity thank you all for giving us
this award it belongs to a lot of people
thanks first of all to Joseph's menu for
writing a wonderful and unique
screenplay that just leapt off the page
the first time I read it
and thanks to our great great
hard-working crew led by the talented
and idealistic Michael Ball house they
they make our job as producers I think a
lot easier and thanks to the actors
especially to my partner Griffin because
they all understood this material
perfectly and and I love every
performance in the movie and lastly
thank you to our director Martin
Scorsese to me marty is a true
independent he never compromises in his
work and he's always pushing himself to
go farther and to be better and he is
secure enough in his own talent to be
open to ideas from everybody and making
movies with him is truly a collaboration
and it is never dull as producers we
have so far we've managed to straddle
the line between independent and
Hollywood and our movies have been
released by the major studios but we've
managed to get them to leave us alone
while we're making them and sometimes it
makes me feel like a character in the
body snatchers I feel like I'm
struggling to stay awake and if I close
my eyes even for a second I'll turn into
a pod
Hollywood and the business of film has a
very strong pull and in this money
oriented time that we live in it's even
harder to stay creatively independent
so I would like to say here's to all of
you and let's not turn into pods and
thank you again I've always imagined
trying to pitch after hours to get a
development feel at a studio it's a
story about a guy whose date kills
herself in the first 20 minutes for the
picture and then he's chased by Mister
Softee ice cream truck for and since
we've made this movie a lot of motion
picture and television studios have said
we want to make an after-hours type
picture and I think they mean movies
with original situations great
characters like so many of the other
exist so many and the other pictures
nominated here today I think it also
means we want original originalitycheck
ill herself and you know no gays kissing
and no rats at all in this picture we're
very glad that we got to make the
picture exactly as we read it and I want
to thank my partner is Amy and Bob Joe
minyan who wrote this extraordinary
screenplay and Martin Scorsese and the
independent film project thanks
I just I would just like to thank Amy
and Griffin for taking me into the fold
and introducing me to the low-budget
concept because I met them back a long
time ago with baby 2 and when they came
to me first with this project and we
talked about Marty Scorsese directing a
film for three million dollars and
having worked with Marty on King of
Comedy I looked at and like they were
crazy absolutely another part but I just
want to thank the IFA for recognizing
all the hard work that goes into
low-budget filmmaking and thank
everybody and knowing that there's a
light at the end of the tunnel in the
film business is a great feeling to me
and a big part of it thank you adlib
congratulations and final remarks and
parentheses this is definitely not in
the script but I would like to say
something aside from the generous
sponsorship of let's say a Kodak or
Louisiana Film Commission which makes an
event possible
I told you I got the script when I got
off the plane don't don't wipe out
actually the fact though which is that
the IFP which is the organizing
principle of this event I'm told
operates under great duress for the
daily operations of secretaries phone
bills all the kind of stuff that we
count on them for and are probably too
proud to stick out a hand and I'm not
going to do it for them except to say
that I certainly and willing to kick in
50 or $100 to say with my money
how much I appreciate them and I think
anybody who can afford to really should
because organizations like this can only
run on inspiration and dedication so
long before the people burnout and I
think that in all the kudos and
congratulations
we might remember that and I was
definitely not asked to say that yes
that's just from me to you and so having
said that I'm probably in trouble but I
I thank you all and gene will close this
event but you can count on
well I want to say that your best
contribution was what you did here today
we really appreciate that and that's
very nice of you to talk about that I'm
embarrassed okay I really want to thank
all our presenters all the speakers are
our sponsors and salute every nominee
and winner and everybody in this room
for being here to celebrate the the
independent spirit that makes us all fly
just before we close I would like our
president Victoria Wozniak to say a
couple of words
this woman was one of the founders of
the IFP you know you speak of vision boy
vision for films yes she does that and
then she had this vision along with a
few other people and they made it a
reality and she works every day to keep
this vision alive and I'm just real
proud to know her and
can I say except Victoria please come up
[Applause]
before I let everybody go home there are
once again I would like to thank Eastman
Kodak and the artisanal commission for
their ongoing support of the IFP as well
as their sponsorship for today's event
really also too I would like you all to
help me thank two women who have
volunteered hundreds of hours for well
over a month and lost hours of sleep
sacrificed their jobs their happy home
life their good health to get this whole
thing together they are to the very best
friends the IFP has miss Jeanne Lucas
and and camel
also the entire board of directors of
the IFP would like to sincerely thank
our executive director she is the
heartbeat of the organization she keeps
us focused she keeps us on track
she is directly responsible for the
growth and the achievements that we've
done within this filmmaking community
more often than that she can pull off
the impossible she is a true little
miracle worker and I like when you think
about it filmmaking really isn't an art
form it's a mechanical process that the
artist chooses to use it's complex and
it's complicated and it's demanding and
it requires the marriage of many talents
writers producers directors actors
technicians and mechag refers bankers
accountants each and individual and each
with his own independent vision and
spirit because it takes the melding of
all these talents and artistry to create
just one motion picture it really is a
miracle that any of them get made at all
I want to thank everyone here today for
your passion and your vision and I'm
sure in many places your blind faith but
mostly your commitment to excellence
because without that we wouldn't have
the pictures that we might have here
I thank you and congratulate you all
you're all winners
[Applause]
[Music]
hello mr. mark congratulations thank you
sir
I just wanted to have 20 seconds
okay